Hey, this is super interesting. Republican
Governor Charlie Baker from Massachusetts,
our governor has announced that he cannot support
Donald Trump for president and will not be voting
for Donald Trump. Now, I've mentioned before
that Massachusetts has this habit of electing
sort of moderate Republican governors. Bill Weld
is an example. Mitt Romney not really a moderate,
but in the modern Republican Party, certainly
less extreme than many other Republicans.
And despite being a very blue state with a
very left wing state legislature, these sort of
more moderate Republicans are frequently elected
governors of Massachusetts. We've also reported
that Charlie Baker is a Republican governor who
has dealt pretty well with coronavirus. I think
now things are starting to get a little out of
hand. I think indoor dining needs to be shut down
and quick because we are back up to six, 700 cases
a day after being down to, you know, 150 and the
like. But overall, Charlie Baker has done pretty
well with the virus. Back when Donald Trump wanted
state National Guard troops sent down to guard
the border, Charlie Baker said, I'm not doing it.
Well, the latest news is that Charlie Baker is
abandoning the Republican Party this November,
at least nationally, and not supporting Donald
Trump, putting out a statement a couple days ago
through his communications director, which
said, quote, The governor cannot support
Donald Trump for president and is focused on
seeing Massachusetts through the pandemic.
He'll leave the election analysis to the pundits.
Now, we already knew Baker didn't vote for Trump
back in 2016. He voted a blank ballot on the
presidency. So this could be a few different
things. This could be that Charlie Baker,
understanding that he's potentially on the ballot
for reelection in a couple years, having one
of the highest approval ratings of any governor
on Corona virus as a Republican in a blue state.
Why would he do something that could torpedo him?
But would it really torpedo him? I don't know.
Massachusetts is a very blue state, but 32 percent
of Massachusetts voters did vote for Trump
in 2016. Now, it's important to understand
a lot of those Massachusetts Republican voters are
very different than Louisiana Republican voters.
South Carolina Republican voters. But still, it's
not clear that supporting Trump would torpedo
Charlie Baker's shot at reelection. It wouldn't
help, but it's not clear it would torpedo it. So
it could really be a personal moral objection to
Donald Trump and less about calculated politics.
But either way, it's very interesting because
it is not common that Republican governors
don't support the Republican candidate for
president. It's equally uncommon that Democratic
governors wouldn't support the Democratic
candidate for president. But you can really
see it in a couple different ways. Now, the other
thing I think is important to mention here is that
these Republican governors like Charlie Baker are
often seen as weird by Republicans in other parts
of the country. There's a really interesting
reality we have to come to terms with,
which is that Charlie Baker really represents
what Republicans used to be in the 60s and 70s.
I would argue that the Republicans that are the
weird ones are the ones that abandoned the school
of thought of people like, you know, William
F. Buckley, for example, and now have turned
into these sycophantic Lindsey Graham, Joni
Ernst types. They are really the wacky ones.
You know, Bill Weld, another example
of a Republican Massachusetts governor
who's really a right leaning libertarian as
an example. And similarly, if you look at the
Republican governors as well as the Republican
electorates in a lot of these other states,
you see dramatically different things. And
it does reflect the Republicans in the state,
Brooke. It happens on the Democratic side as well.
Brooklyn Democrats and South Carolina Democrats
are very different. There's no question about
that and much the same way rural Pennsylvania
Republicans and Boston suburb Republicans are very
different. One Republican governor, at minimum,
is a band. Donald Trump, we will see if anybody
else does. In any case, I would expect a Donald
Trump tweet or attack of some kind on Charlie
Baker calling him a rhino, a Republican in name
only. Maybe he's already referred to Charlie Baker
that way. And I just don't remember. But doing the
right thing, I, I like that Charlie Baker is doing
this. We have a fantastic program for you today.
Later on in the show, we are going to talk
about what should happen with the Electoral
College. What can change the presidential race at
this late stage? And very importantly, will the
voter turnout explosion actually happen this year?
We're seeing way more early voting than we've ever
seen before. But we are in a pandemic where early
voting has been encouraged, like it's never been
encouraged before. Every party, every election
likes to say we vote. We have enthusiasm and we
are going to win on record turnout this year. Is
it actually going to happen? All of those and your
calls will be discussed later on in the program.
Make sure you're following me on Twitter at
David Pakman. And we will take a quick
break and be back right after this.